when you said they they they they and i
said who is they who's at the top of
they and you said fitzgerald and he said
comey and then he said you know mueller
some of these names that you said and
then now when i say why didn't obama
pardon you because you said obama was a
part of it so now let's go to that party
and if obama's a part of it my
speculation becomes if obama so because
sometimes
i feel like you know uh
when jerry buss
gets a call from shaq and shaq says hey
jerry
riley and the heat offered me 20 million
a year if you match me i'll stay with
you at the lakers you know what jerry
buss told him
he said i think you should take that
offer because i can match that offer and
what does shaq do he goes to miami what
does jerry do he locks and who kobe
right okay similar call happened when
pat riley called jerry buss and said hey
listen i'm getting a massive contract
from the knicks you want to match it
i'll stay i don't want to leave the
lakers but they're offering like 5.5
million or whatever the number was and
he's like dude i can't pay you that you
go take that contract right i feel like
at one point
and i'm seeing this trend on both
political parties when they lock on to
someone everybody becomes indispensable
right and somebody has to almost take a
blame for something so during kovid you
know the first six months the rock star
okovid was who
he was a rock star right every day we
heard cuomo cuomo como he's the next
presidential candidate him and his
brothers would go at it
and then something happened behind
closed doors that i don't think any one
of us will ever know what happened there
where he either didn't say yes or he
either thought he was bigger than the
political party pelosi and these guys
flipped on him next thing you know hey
you got to resign he resigned then his
brother boom then you know zucker boom
they're not cmo boom we saw what the
trickle effect was all the way down
do you think it was a position right
that time all these guys behind closed
doors said um
look that guy's a governor he's probably
not going to be the president this guy's
a senator he had a great speech at the
dnc in 2004. we can get behind this guy
let's back him up let's throw this guy
under the bus and let's go do you think
a conversation like that took place
beyond closed doors
no i don't think so i don't i don't
think it was like that i think it was
that these federal prosecutors some of
them are just
unscrupulous
guys who abuse their power and make big
names for themselves by being big game
hunters and this guy was chasing me for
a long long time i think he was also
chasing obama because of rusco and so
when rescue got indicted on stuff that
had nothing to do with me or obama so he
was trying to get obama as well
i believe this is my belief
i'll give you my belief on how it all
shook out
so what happened was because resco was
closer to obama than he was to me he
actually bought him property obama
bought a big mansion after his elected
state's united states senator and then
the lot the adjoining lot
this guy rusco bought for obama
and then when the heat was on
politically obama gave him a bill and
bresco paid 13 000 to put a fence up but
the 750 000 lot that was paid at this
price by
resco was basically for obama it was
like a adjoining lot to the mansion that
he bought
so
they were looking at both of us i think
because of resco and they were right to
look at rusco there were allegations
related to stuff that he was doing
in the
in any event he finally gets convicted
rusco does and they're squeezing them to
say stuff about the two of us he puts
out a letter to the sentencing judge and
says that these federal prosecutors are
trying to make me say things about
governor blagojevich and senator obama
he actually listed me first
i'm not going to lie about those two
guys just to save myself i've never been
involved in any wrongdoing
says that yeah it's a matter of public
record made the front page of the
chicago tribune the big fear was would
rescue lie to save himself because they
squeeze these people
you know with scaring with long
sentences but if they'll say certain
things they want them to say singer
compose you know then they get lighter
sentences that was the big fear but when
resco did that both of us were
in real good place that's when they
started putting the fbi tapes on me
but then when they arrested me here's
what i think happened with obama they
immediately went to obama and they
interviewed him because he was involved
in the case
and those are called fbi 302s to this
day they still won't give us my team my
lawyers the fbi 302s of obama's
interview which is absolutely relevant
to a criminal defendant me
in the facing what i was facing they
have to give you that they they didn't
and they still won't so they've got that
sort of under seal as well
i think obama made a calculation as
political people made a calculation that
when fitzgerald made that big move
arrested a sitting governor in such a
dramatic way the way he did i was
politically radioactive they did this on
purpose everybody ran it's like the ship
is sinking and the
everybody jumps overboard right obama
was no different and he was saving
himself politically not wanting to get
caught up in any of that and so they i
was sold out in the process so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast click over here
take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]